representatives from Sudan's warring
sides are in Saudi Arabia for talks
along with a senior un official
delegates from the Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces have
said they would only discuss a
humanitarian truce and not an end to the
conflict hundreds of people have been
killed in the fighting so far that began
three weeks ago and as Heber Morgan
reports from Khartoum even as the talks
get underway Bloodshed continues in the
capital
a Sudanese army tank comes under attack
in hartum
and fires back at positions held by the
paramilitary rapid support forces as
representatives from the Rival sides
meet in Jeddah for talks fighting is
continuing around the presidential
Palace the Sudanese Army has increased
its attacks on the rapid support forces
in many parts of the capital especially
around the presidential Palace there's
been more airstrikes near the compound
and in other parts of the city where the
rsf is thought to be positioned the rsf
has responded with surface-to-air
missiles and other Heavy Artillery
amid the conflicts looting in North
Khartoum this meat factory was set on
fire
I don't know the source of the fire
another fire also broke out days later
in a furniture store near us people Loot
and burn that's what they do they also
burned another place not far from here
this Factory belongs to one of the
largest food packaging companies in
Sudan
we received materials 10 days ago the
looters came and asked us about the
contents of the cartons then they slit
the cartons open with knives and looted
what was inside this has happened
several times
more people are fleeing the capital in
Port Sudan on the Eastern Red Sea Coast
authorities are struggling to cope
we hope the United Nations envelope
who's now in Port Sudan will sort out
the problem of the syrians and the Yemen
is in particular this solution could be
to evacuate them to their countries or
to another country or to put them in
refugee camps outside the state so as
not to face problems and security
challenges because of their large
numbers
Crescent is treating ventured basically
recently cases of malaria have appeared
most of the existing medications are
antibiotics pain relievers as well as
diabetes and blood pressure medications
we have comprehensive medications but
they are not sufficient
these people are waiting to leave the
country but millions of others are
trapped by the fighting and struggling
to get medicine food or water Heber
Morgan Al Jazeera cartoon
The Source said are reports from King
Faisal naval base in Jeddah where a ship
has arrived carrying yemenis who was
stranded in Port Sudan
Journey on the Red Sea the first ship
carrying the yemenis who were stranded
into Sudan has finally arrived in Jeddah
in King Faisal Naval base and those are
the yemenis that were stranded in Port
Sudan for days and days so two ships
were expected to arrive in this base
this is the first one in total today
Saudi Arabia is receiving more than four
more than
470 yemenis here these people are
running from a brutal war on the other
side of the the the sea so here that the
ambulances Medical Teams are receiving
them they're one welcome presented by
the Roses by officials here and then
they will get on the buses and being
taken to the hotels a temporary place
that they are going to stay in and Saudi
officials are saying that they have been
granted one month residence visa the
spokesperson of the Saudi Naval forces
has told me that so far Saudi India has
received 7 800 evacuates from uh from
Port Sudan so here the the the the force
frantic Force are on the way to welcome
and shelter them however on the other
side of the sea the war between the
paramilitary rapid support forces and
Sudan's Army which were supposed to
protect Sudanese are still fighting each
other and import Sudan there are still
thousands desperately waiting to be
evacuated
Al Jazeera King Faisal naval base in
Jeddah
and some Sudanese refugees are crossing
the border into Ethiopia carrying their
belongings and Provisions on Donkey
carts they have to register with the
International Organization for migration
to get Aid the UN estimates that more
than 800 000 people with flee violence
from Sudan
meanwhile Qatar sent a third plane
carrying essential supplies to Port
Sudan more than 20 tons of food and
medical supplies were delivered on
Sunday shops remain closed as fighting
continues in many parts of the country
so food and water are scarce relief
flight return to Castle was 71 Sudanese
evacuees on board
everything lack of water lack of fuel
lack of medicine lack of even hospitals
and doctors and but we suffer for the
last three days
until we arrive to Bar Sudan no sleep no
food no nothing